les phrases à rentrer dans ta boîte à
idées
j'arrive pas à bree
c'est trop du mottay
mes parents ils sont de base chef de
choeur dans une paroisse dans le sud de
l'île donc j'ai baigné dans une église
dans la kora j'ai fait mes premières
animations très jeune j'ai chanté des
sommes très très jeunes aussi et je suis
vraiment issu d'une famille de musiciens
et
ouais c'est vraiment dans le sens et
chez ses parents
m
mon univers en fait il est très très
éclectique finalement j'ai pas vraiment
de l'endroit où nous poser je suis comme
un oiseau j'aime bien toucher à
plusieurs niveaux mais pourvu que ça me
correspondent
mais j'ai pas d'univers précis mais
c'est vrai que là le prochain album qui
va sortir et le plus pop électro et
voilà j'ai voulu ouvrir ma musique à un
public un peu plus large
[Musique]
on est en saison des amours apparemment
vous savez moi j'ai une vision très très
spécial de l'amo pour moi l'amour n'a
pas de limites et c'est vraiment ce
message qu'on voulait faire passer avec
sièges c'est que enfin moi
personnellement je suis une grande
romantique je suis amoureuse de la vie
amoureuse de mai situation de mes
évolution des gens qui m'entourent
amoureuse des gens qui sont fiers de moi
et c'est vraiment ce message-là ce côté
universel de l'amour qu'on a voulu faire
passer dans cette chanson là avec cf
[Musique]
comment tu vois l'avenir à court terme
alors je le vois comme je le vois depuis
depuis que j'ai commencé à vivre de la
musique c'est à dire que moi j'ai
vraiment envie de continuer sur le
chemin de la professionnalisation de la
musique je suis intermittent du
spectacle
donc voilà je veux vraiment pouvoir
faire en sorte de de pouvoir continuer
encore et encore à vivre le plus
longtemps possible de l'année
[Musique]
le